[संगीत]
ब
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग एक बार मुझे यह
बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है नहीं आ
रही बस चैट में यस या नो बता
दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू वेलकम टू टोनिक्स अकेडमी डे
फाइव ऑफ दिस बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग कोर्स फ
स्पेशल फॉर बग
बाउंटीज
तो स्टार्ट करने से पहले सबको एक चीज बता
देता हूं अगर अगर नहीं पता आप लोगों को
मैंने अभी तक अगर लास्ट क्लासेस में नहीं
बताई हो तो हमने क्या कर दिया एक अपनी खुद
की प लंच कर दिया जहां पर आप लाइव कोर्स
अटेंड कर सकते हैं या फदर जो भी कोर्सेस
आएंगे वहां पर आप बहुत ही कम प्राइस में
और क्वालिटी कंटेंट आपको वहां पर देखने को
मिल जाएगा लाइक अभी यमी जैसा प्लेटफॉर्म
है नहीं बट उससे बेटर हम बनाने की कोशिश
करेंगे उसको तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
अभी मैं
इधर पर दिखा देता हूं मोबाइल पर शो नहीं
कर सकता बाकी क्या करना आपको
डेनिक्स
यह हमारी ओनली अभी क्या है कि प्ले स्टोर
पर ही अवेलेबल है अ डेनिक करोगे तो यह इस
तरीके से इस टाइप के लोगों के साथ हमारे
डेनिक्स नाम जो एप्लीकेशंस है वोह एप्स
अवेलेबल है हमारे ग प्ले स्टोर पर और
जल्दी आईफो के लिए भी आ जाएगी तो प्लीज
अगर किसी ने इसको डाउनलोड नहीं किया है तो
डाउनलोड कीजिए अपने मोबाइल में और रजिस्टर
कर लीजिए अपने मोबाइल नंबर के साथ फदर
बेनिफिट उठाने के
लिए यह थी आप लोगों के लिए एक गुड न्यूज
जो मैंने पहले बता देना चाहिए था बट आई एम
स्किप फ्रॉम माय
माइंड चलो फिर लास्ट क्लास में हमने क्या
बात किया था कि जो टोकेनाइजेशन है उसके
बारे में मैंने बताया था टोकेनाइजेशन क्या
होता है ठीक है और उसमें वो क्या करता है
कि मेटा कैक्टस के बेसिस पर आपके कमांड
लाइन को ब्रेक करता है टोकन के अंदर और
टोकन प फरदर जब एक बार रफ आईडी आपको मिल
जाता तो उस उसके बाद टोकेंस को दो कैटेगरी
में डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है जिसको हम
बोलते हैं वर्ड और ऑपरेटर वर्ड में वर्ड
कौन से होंगे कौन से होते हैं वो आपको पता
है अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं
ऑपरेटर्स
आपके वर्ड्स में क्या है एक भी अनकोटेड
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स नहीं होता और ऑपरेटर्स
में एटलीस्ट वन अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
होता है उसके बाद क जो ऑपरेटर्स भी दो
टाइप्स के होते हैं ये आपको पता है तो आज
जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं आज जो हमारा टॉपिक
है
वह है स्टेप टू कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन यह
थोड़ा सा रिवीजन क्विक रिवीजन करना जरूरी
है क्योंकि हर एक चीज एक दस रिलेटेड
है चलो हम अपने पेज डे फ पर आ जाते हैं यह
रहा तो
चलो जो आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं वो है
स्टेप स्टेप ट जिसको हम बोलते हैं कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कमांड
आइडेंटी फिकेशन कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन जिसको
हम बोलते हैं कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन इसको एक बार हाईलाइट
कर देता आप लोगों के
लिए ओके कमांड आइडेंट स्टेप टू है आज इसके
बारे डिकस करने वाले स्टेप टू के बारे में
हम क्या करने वाले हैं डिस्कस करने वाले
हैं अब बात करते हैं कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
की ओके देखो बेसिकली क्या होता है ना आपके
पास दो टाइप्स की कमांड्स होती है बेसिकली
आपके पास देरर टू टाइप्स ऑफ कमांड्स
देयर
आर टू टाइप्स
ऑफ कमांड्स
दो टाइप के कमांड होते हैं आपके पास उसको
कैसे आड इसको किया तो था इतने ब यार लग जब
कर दिया दो टाइप की कमांड होती है कौन कन
सी एक तो होती हैको बोलते हैं सिंपल
कमांड सिंपल कमांड होती है एक तो सिंपल
कमांड दूसरी जो होती है
आपकी सीओ ए प ओ यू एनडी कंपाउंड कमांड
कंपाउंड कमांड दूसरी आपकी होती है कंपाउंड
कमांड कंपाउंड कमांड अ इसका थोड़ा सा कलर
पहले जैसा कर देता हं
यह ओके दो टाइप्स की होती
है एक सिंपल कमांड दूसरी होती है आपकी
कंपाउंड कमांड्स
कंपाउंड कमांड्स देखि क्या है जब एक बार
आपका टोकेनाइजेशन स्टेप हो जाता है उसके
बाद जो सेकंड स्टेप आता है कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन उसमें क्या है यह कमांड इन
दो टाइप्स के कमांड्स के बारे में
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
मोस्टली वो कॉमन कमांड्स होती है जो हम
डेली बेसिस पर अपने नक् मशीन में यूज़
करते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल आप एको करते हो या
इफ कॉन्फ़िग करते हो या कोई भी जो कमांड
यूज करते हो डेली बेसिस पर वह सिंपल कमांड
कहलाती है फर एपल मैं एक एग्जांपल लेकर
दिखाता आपको मैं एक और बॉक्स ओपन कर लेता
हूं फ एपल आज मुझे क्या कमांड लान की
जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी इधर समझा दूंगा फर
एजाल एक एग्जांपल लेते हैं हम इसको समझाने
के लिए जब भी आप क्या करते हो अपने मशीन
में क्या टाइप करते हो
एक और उसके बाद वन स्पेस टू स्पेस ्र ऐसा
टाइप करते जब भी आप अपनी मशीन में क्या
करते ऐसा टाइप करता एक बार साइज बढ़ा देता
लोग के
लिए
य ओके जब भी आप क्या करते हो ऐसा टाइप
करते हो अपनी मशीन के अंदर एक
टूथ तो जो पहला वर्ड होता है कमांड में जब
भी नॉर्मली क्या होता है जब भी जो पहला
वर्ड होता है मैं आपको समझा देता हूं जो
फर्स्ट वर्ड
एक मिनट कंट्रोल
चट ट इ द
इ सॉरी फॉट जो लिखा था वही वापस से चला
गया मेरा प्रॉब्लम हो गया रुको
रुको चलो इसको हम हटा देंगे
हम एग्जांपल लेते हैं
य फर
एग्जांपल एपल मैंने क्या किया एकको किया न
टू और ्र मैंने जब भी टर्मिनल फायर करता
हूं तो क्या होता है देखो इसको मैं बार
आपके लिए हाईलाइट कर देता
हूं जो सबसे पहला वर्ड होता है इसमें
सिंपल कमा कमांड जो सबसे पहला वर्ड होता
है उसको जो इंटरप्रेटर है उसको इंटरप्रेटर
क्या करता है एज ए कमांड इंटरप्रेट करता
है इसको एज ए कमांड मान के चलता है कि जो
पहला जो वर्ड होगा आपके टर्मिनल में आपके
सेल के अंदर उसको क्या करके मान के चलता
है ये कमांड का नाम होगा सबसे पहले क्या
नाम होगा कमांड का नेम होगा उसके बाद
रिमेनिंग जो रिमेनिंग वन टू थ जो स्पेस
सेपरेटली तीन वर्ड्स जो बच जाते हैं आपको
उसको हम क्या समझ जो आपका इंटरप्रेटर क्या
समझता है या तो वो कमांड इस कमांड के लिए
इनपुट होगा या आर्गुमेंट होंगे कुछ भी बोल
सकते हैं तो बेसिकली यह चीज आपको समझ में
आती होगी सिंपल कमांड के अंदर तो फर्स्ट
वर्ड क्या होता है आपका कमांड समझा जाता
है उसके बाद स्पेस सेपरे जितने भी वर्ड
होते हैं तो इस कमांड के इनपुट समझे जाते
हैं या आर्गुमेंट समझे जाते हैं यह सबको
समझ में आ रहा होगा मैं इसको बताने की को
इससे करता हूं एक
मिनट यह रहा
चलो इसको हम बोले फर्स्ट वर्ड को हम क्या
बोलेंगे
कमांड नेम इसको हम कमांड
नेम जो इसको क्या है कमांड नेम कमांड समझा
जाएगा इसको क्या सम जाएगा कमांड इसको समझा
जाएगा
कमांड ओके और बाकी जो तीन वर्ड बच जाएंगे
बाकी जो ी बाकी थी लेप य जो तीन बच जाएंगे
बाकी ्र इनको क्या समझा जाएगा
इनको समझा जाएगा या
तो इंटर पट
एज कमांड
इनपुट्स या क्या समझा जाएगा आर्गुमेंट
आर्गुमेंट
ऑफ ट
कमांड इस कमांड के य समझा जाएगा तीन चीजों
ओके येय ये चीज समझ जाएगी आई होप ये समझ
में आ रहा होगा एक और चीज होता है सिंपल
कमांड्स के बारे में एक और चीज होती है
सिंपल कमांड्स के बारे में क्या होता है
कि जितनी भी सिंपल कमांड्स होती हैं वो
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के द्वारा ही टमेंट की
जाती है वो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के द्वारा ही
टर्मिनेट की जाती है अब आप लोगों के दिमाग
में यह सवाल आ रहा होगा कि दोय कमांड है
एकको 1 2 3 इसके पीछे तो कोई भी कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर नहीं है लेकिन क्या होता है कि एट
द एंड ऑफ एवरी कमांड लाइन हर एक कमांड
लाइन के एंड में क्या होता है एक न्यू
लाइन कैरेक्टर्स होता है जिसका काम क्या
होता है कमांड को टर्मिनेट करने का काम
होता है एक इनविजिबल न्यू लाइन कैरेक्टर्स
होता है जो कि दिखाई नहीं देता लेकिन हर
एक कमांड लाइन के एंड में होता है उस
कमांड को टर्मिनेट करने के लिए और जो
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स की बात मैं कर रहा हूं
कि कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर का यूज किया जाता है
सिंपल कमांड्स को क्या करने के लिए
परमानेंट करने के लिए कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
कौन-कौन से होते हैं अगर आपको ने मालूम है
तो मैं क्या करता हूं आपको एक बार शो करके
दिखा देता हूं यह कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स होते
हैं न्यू लाइन उसके बा पाइप सिंबल डबल
पाइप सिंबल ए परसेंट डबल ए परसेंट सेमीकलन
डबल सेमीकलन सेमीकलन ए परसेंट डबल सेमीकलन
m परसेंट पाइप सिंबल एम परसेंट उसके बाद
ओपन कर ली ओपन ब्रैकेट और क्लोज ब्रैकेट
ये सारे सारे कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के अंदर आते
हैं यह लिस्ट मैं कल की क्लास में आपको
बता चुका हूं ये आपको सबके समझ में आ गया
होगा अब फॉर एग्जांपल एक एग्जांपल लेता
हूं मैं चलो ये तो था
एक बिल्कुल सिंपल सा एग्जांपल फॉर
एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया एक और एग्जांपल
मैंने क्या लिया यह रहा अने टर्मिनल में
कमांड फायर की
एकको
नटू 3 उसके बाद आपने लिखा एकको उसके बाद ए
बी डी आपने ये लिखा ए बीडी इसको क्या करता
हूं हाईलाइट कर देता आप लोगों के
लिए ये रहा इसको बड़ा कर देता अ कमांड है
ये आपके टर्मिनल में कमांड है ये आपको
सबको दिखाई दे रही होगी क्लियर तो अब ये
देखिए ये कमांड आपने अपने टर्मिनल में
टाइप की तो सबसे पहले क्या होगा सबसे पहले
क्या होता है जब भी आप कोई भी कमांड आपके
टर्मिनल पर आपके सेल पर टाइप की जाती है
मै साल के ऊपर तो वहां पर क्या होता
है सबसे पहला स्टेप क्या होता है टोकना
इजेशन होता है सबसे पहला क्या होता है
टोकना इजेशन होता है टोकेनाइजेशन में क्या
होता है कि आपकी जो कमांड है कमांड लाइन
है उसको क्या किया जाता अनकोटेड मेटा
कक्टर के बेसिस पर क्या किया जाता है
ब्रेक किया जाता है चंक्स में ब्रेक किया
जाता है जिनको हम टोकस बोलते हैं अब
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर कौन से होते हैं
अगर आपको नहीं मालूम है तो मैं एक बार
आपको दिखा देता हूं लेकिन प्रीवियस क्लास
में हमने पढ़ा
था ये
रहा यह होते मेटा कैरेक्टर टोटल 10 मेटा
कैरेक्टर होते हैं ये रहे आपको ये लिस्ट
आपको देखने को मिल रही होगी ये होते है 10
मेटा कैरेक्टर रु रुको रुको रुको ये रहा
ये होते हैं वो 10 मेटा कैरेक्टर्स अब
इनको मैं बात कर रहा हूं अनकोटेड मेटा
कक्टर अगर आपको यह डिफरेंस मालूम नहीं है
कि कोटेड क्या होता है और अनकोटेड क्या
होता है तो आप डे थ्री की क्लास में जाइए
उसके बाद पूरा ये 30 मिनट्स का एक लेक्चर
है कोटिंग के ऊपर वो अच्छे से समझिए तो
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि कोटेड कौन से
कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं और अनकोटेड
कैरेक्टर्स कौन से होते हैं तो आपको ये
मालूम चल गया कि जब भी कोई भी कमांड आपके
टर्मिनल में बैस सेल पे टाइप की जाती है
फायर की जाती है सबसे पहला जो स्टेप होता
है वो होता है टोकेनाइजेशन टोकेनाइजेशन
में क्या होता है ंक्स में कमांड को
डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ अ
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स और अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स के आधार पर जब एक बार रफ
आईडिया ले लिया जाता है कि कहां पर टोकेंस
हैं तो एक बार अब हम क्या करते हैं इसको
ब्रेक करते हैं लाइन को तो अभी यहां पर आप
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा अगर मैं इस
कमांड को ब्रेक करूं तो देखो सबसे पहले ये
स्पेस दिख रहा है एक स्पेस क्योंकि स्पेस
भी क्या है
एक मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है व भी अनकोटेड है
कोट तो नहीं है ये उसके बाद वन के बाद भी
फिर क्या स्पेस दो तीन फिर चार एक के बाद
फिर पांच उसके बाद ए के बाद छ उसके बाद बी
के बाद सात मतलब टोटल क्या है यहां पर
सेवन स्पेस है दे टोटल अगर मैं बात करता
हूं यहां पर टोटल सेवन
स्पेस तो एक बार कमांड ने क्या रफ आईडिया
लगा लिया कि कहां पर है टोकेनाइजेशन कहां
कहां पर है टोकना इजेशन टोकस कहां पर है
तो टोटल कितने है टोटल
07 स्पेस है स्पेस भी क्या है मेटा
कैरेक्टर है अब रफ आईडिया लगा लिया अब
उसके बाद कमांड क्या उसके बाद टोकना स्टेप
में क्या होता है जब एक बार आपको पता चल
जाता है कि कहां क पर टोकन है उसके बाद
उसको वर्ड्स और किसके अंदर ब्रेक किया
जाता है वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर्स के अंदर ब्रेक
किया जाता है अब क्या होगा आपका कमांड
कैसे रीड किया जाता है सबसे पहला ई सी एच
ओ एक अभी क्या वर्ड्स कौन से होते हैं
आपको पता है वर्ड वो टोकन होते हैं है
जिसके अंदर या हमें बोल सिंपल भाषा में
बोलू कि सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स दैट डज
नॉट कंटेन एनी सिंगल अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स जिसके अंदर एक भी अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स नहीं होता उसको हम एज ए वर्ड
कंसीडर करते हैं तो ई सी एच ओ एकको आ गया
तो एकको क्या है एक वर्ड है उसके तुरंत
बाद क्या स्पेस आ गया स्पेस क्या है एक
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है अब मेटा कैरेक्टर्स आ
गया तो ऑपरेटर आ गया अब ऑपरेटर कौन से
होते हैं जिसके अंदर एटलीस्ट एक अनकोटेड
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स होता है तो अब एकको एक
वर्ड हो गया उसके बाद कंट्रोल कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर आ गया उसके बाद नेक्स्ट वन वन आ
गया वन के अंदर वन के साथ फिर क्या है फिर
स्पेस आ गया तो मतलब यहां टोटल कितने
वर्ड्स हो गए एकको एक वर्ड वन दो वर्ड टू
थ्री वर्ड थ्री फोर वर्ड एकको फाइव वर्ड
फिर ए बी सी डी ये सारे क्या है
इंडिविजुअल वर्ड्स है उसके बाद यहां पर
क्या है ऑपरेटर्स है बट क्या है कि यहां
पर जो स्पेस है स्पेस ना तो कोई कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर है ना ही रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर है ये
आपको समझ में आ रहा होगा ना ही कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर ना ही रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर ऑपरेटर
तो है बट क्या है कि यहां पर ना कोई
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर ना ही रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर
है तो यहां पर टोटल कितने वर्ड्स हो गए एक
दो तीन चार पाच 6 सात आ टोटल आठ वर्ड्स हो
गए और ऑपरेटर्स में क्या है स्पेस हो गया
अब आपको कंडीशन क्या पता है जो सिंपल
कमांड लाइंस होती है उनको टर्मिनेट किसके
आधार पर किया जाता है
क्या है परमिट करने कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर की
जरूरत पड़ती है अब इसके बीच में कोई भी
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं है तो क्या होगा जो
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन स्टेप में इस कमांड
को एक सिंगल सिंपल कमांड ही समझा जाएगा
इसको कंसीडर क्या किया जाएगा सिंगल सिंपल
कमांड ही इसको कंसीडर किया जाएगा तो अब
मैं बात यह
[संगीत]
रहा इसको क्या कंसीडर किया इन्होने सिंगल
सिंपल
ओके बिल्कुल
यह एक सिंगल सिंपल कमांड कंसीडर किया
इन्होने
सिंगल
सिंपल कमांड ये सिंगल सिंपल कमांड है यह
शायद आपको इस एग्जांपल समझ में आ रहा होगा
इसको क्या किया सिंगल सिंपल कमांड्स के
कंसीडर किया नेक्स्ट एक और एग्जांपल लेता
हूं मैं अगला एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया एक
एग्जांपल लेता हूं यहां पर मैं थोड़ा
स्क्रोल डाउन करते हैं नेक्स्ट एग्जांपल
मेरा ये रहा अब मैं क्या करता हूं एकको
किया मैंने और अबके बार मैंने क्या लिया
डॉलर उसके बाद नेम लिखा मैंने नेक्स्ट पे
सेपरेटेड ग्रेटर देन सिंबल नेक्स्ट मैंने
क्या लिखा आउट डटी एकटी मैंने अबके बार
मैंने ये कमांड अपने टर्मिनल में फायर की
ये कमांड मैंने अपने टर्मिनल में क्या की
फयर की अब मैं इसको क्या हाईलाइट कर देता
ये रहा एको अब यहां पर क्या है आपको पता
है सबसे पहले क्या होगा कि टोकना स्टेप
होगा टोकेनाइजेशन स्टेप होगा तो एकको उसके
बाद क्या है स्पेस है स्पेस मतलब एक
अनकोटेड मेट कक्टर है डॉलर नेम डॉलर कोई
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स नहीं है मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स ही नहीं है उसके बाद डॉलर नेम
नेक्स्ट फिर एक और स्पेस है ये भी क्या है
एक क्या है अनकोटेड मेटा नेक्स्ट ग्रेटर
देन सिंबल भी एक अनकोटेड मेटा कैक्टस है
स्पेस अनकोटेड मेट आड्स एक और यह क्या है
एक और वर्ड है तो अब उसके बाद उस रफ
आईडिया मिल गया कि कहां पर अनकोटेड मेटा
कक्टर है जब यहां पर अनकोटेड मे कक्टर के
बारे में पता चल गया तो यहा पर क्या आपको
मालूम चला य पर हमें मालूम चला
की यहां
पर थ्री स्पेस
है एंड एक ग्रेटर देन सिंबल है ग्रेटर देन
एस वाई एम बी ओ एक ग्रेटर देन सिंबल है अब
ग्रेटर ये चीज य पर पता चली तो अब क्या
किया रफ आईडिया मिलने के बाद अब क्या इसको
वर्ड्स और किसके अंदर ऑपरेटर के अंदर
डिवाइड किया जाएगा वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर के
अंदर डिवाइड किया जाता अब वर्ड कौन-कौन से
यहां पर ई सी एओ एकको एक वर्ड है उसके बाद
स्पेस आ गया उसके बाद नेक्स्ट डॉलर नेम एक
वर्ड है उसके बाद स्पेस फिर आ ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल अब ये क्या है एक अनकोटेड मेटा
कक्टर है तो ये वर्ड हो ही नहीं सकता तो
ये एक ऑपरेटर है अब आउट डटी एक्सटी क्या
है एक और वर्ड है तो यहां पर तीन वर्ड है
एक ऑपरेटर्स है वो भी कौन सा रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर है आपको पता है रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर
कौन सा सिंबल होता है अगर नहीं मालूम आपको
दिखाता ये रहा ग्रेटर दन सिंबल
रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के अंदर आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है तो यहां पर पता चल गया कि आपको
तीन वर्ड्स है और ऑपरेटर्स है लेकिन
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर नहीं है रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर आपको यहां पर देखने को मिल रहा है
तो आपको पता है लेकिन कंडीशन वही है कि
सिंपल के अंदर कमांड टर्मिनेट करने के लिए
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर चाहिए तो यह भी क्या है कि
कमांड आइडेंट स्टेप में इसको क्या कंसीडर
किया जाएगा इसको भी
एक सी और मैं क्या करता इसके अंदर इसको भी
क्या एक सिंपल कमांड ही कंसीडर किया जाएगा
इसको क्या किया जाएगा सिंपल कमांड कंसीडर
किया
जाएगा य इसको भी एक सिंपल सिंगल सिंपल
कमांड कंसीडर किया जाएगा क्योंकि इसके
अंदर भी कोई भी कंट्रोल हां लेकिन जो
रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर की बात कर रहे हो
कंट्रोल नहीं है लेकिन इसको भी इसका पार्ट
माना जाएगा इसी के सिंपल कमांड के अंदर
इसको कंसीडर किया जो सबसे लास्ट में अपना
टास्क परफॉर्म करता है ओके तो यह भी सिंपल
कमांड नेक्स्ट एक और एग्जांपल लेता हूं
आपके सामने कि अब एक और इंटरेस्टिंग
एग्जांपल
है एक और इंटरेस्टिंग एग्जांपल लेता हूं
मैं आपके
सामने ये रहा बार जो मेरा एग्जांपल है
आपके सामने लेने वाला हूं यह है मैंने
लिखा
एकको
नटू ी उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया सेमीकलन
नेक्स्ट स्पेस दिया मैंने उसके बाद एकको
किया नेक्स्ट मैंने क्या
किया एकको उसके बाद ए बी सी ए बी सी मैंने
कर दिया अबके बार ऐसा कर दिया अबके बार
मैंने क्या किया ये किया अब आपको क्या है
सबसे पहले वही सिंगल सिंपल स्टेप्स है कि
कम टोकेनाइजेशन होगा टोकेनाइजेशन होगा तो
क्या होगा स्पेस और यहां पर सेमीकलन यह
क्या
है यहां पर टोकन है अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर तो
य पर नटू थ फर फ 6 से 8 आ स्पेस है और एक
सेमी कोलन है वो क्या है
आपका
वो भी अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है अब जब
एक बार रफ आईडिया मिल गया टोकस कहां पर है
तो उसके बाद क्या इसको वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर
में डिवाइड किया जाएगा तो यहां पर वर्ड्स
कितने हैं एकको टूथ 4 और आठ चार वर्ड्स है
उसके बाद इसमें ऑपरेटर्स भी है एक
ऑपरेटर्स है वो भी कौन सा ऑपरेटर है अबकी
बार कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कौन सा ऑपरेटर है बात
करें यहां पर तो ये है कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर ये रहा ये है आपका कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर ये आपका कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
य आपका है कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर यह समझ में आ
रहा होगा क्योंकि कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कैसे हो
आपको पता है सेमी कोलस जो आता कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर के अंदर कंसीडर किया जाता है तो
अबकी बार क्या है कंट्रोल पटर तो आपको पता
है कि जब कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन हो रहा होता
है तो सिंपल कमांड को टर्मिनेट करने के
लिए कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर की जरूरत पड़ती है
सिंपल कमांड को टर्मिनेट करने के लिए
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर की जरूरत पड़ती है अब हम
इसको क्या करते यह रहा इसको मैं थोड़ा सा
अगर थोड़ा सा बड़ा कर देता हूं यह रहा धा
हो जा य
रहा इसको थोड़ा नीचे ले लेते हैं ताकि
आपको क्लियर समझ में आ जाए यह क्या चीज है
कंट्रोलर और इसका
थोड़ा अब उसके बाद जब कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
हुआ और किसके बेसिस इसको क्या कर दिया
गया डिवाइड गया तो इसको क्या जो फर्स्ट य
पार्ट आ गया ये वाला ये रहा अगर मैं इसकी
बात
करू इसको टर्मिनेट कर दिया इसने य पर
किसको कर दिया इसको एक टर्मिनेट कर दिया
तो इसको एक सिंपल कमांड समझा जाएगा इसको
क्या किया
जाएगा अब एक यह सिंपल कमांड
है यह रहा उसके बाद यहां पर
दूसरी कंट्रोल
सी
कंट्रोल
ये
रहा यह क्या
है दूसरा अगर मैं इसको क्या करता हूं लाइट
करता हूं
इसको
ना ये रहा ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या है दो
सिंपल कमांड्स है यहां पर क्या है दो
सिंपल कमांड्स है एक टूथ और एक ए बी सी
क्योंकि कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर आ गया और उसके
बेसिस प इसको टर्मिनेट कर दिया गया तो यह
था आपका कांसेप्ट किसका कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन में सिंपल कमांड्स का तो
सिंपल कमांड्स कौन सी होती है आपको पता चल
गया कि सिंपल कमांड बेसिकली सारी वो सिंपल
कमांड्स होती है लेकिन सिंपल कमांड जो
टर्मिनेट की जाती है उसको कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
के द्वारा ही टर्मिनेट किया जाता है और
इससे आपको यह भी पता चल गया कि लास्ट
क्लास में जो मैंने टोकेनाइजेशन समझाया था
कि उसको कैसे यूज किया जा रहा है कमांड्स
के ऊपर तो आपको आई होप ये चीज क्लियर आ
रही होगी क्लियर होगी अभी तक
अगर किसी को डाउट है तो अभी चैट में एक
बार यस नो बता दीजिए तब तक हम चलते हैं
कंपाउंड कमांड्स के बारे में कंपाउंड
कमांड कौन सी होती
है
चलो फिर कंपाउंड कमांड्स के बारे में आपको
बताता हूं कंपाउंड कमांड कौन सी होती है
जो जिसकी बात करने है सिंपल कमांड आपको
समझ में आ गया वो कंपाउंड कमांड्स कौन से
होते हैं
देखो
ईच इच
कंपाउंड कमांड इच कंपाउंड कमांड्स
स्टर्ट्स विद स्टार्टस विद ए आर ई एस ई आर
वी
रिजर्व्ड वर्ड्स रिजर्व्ड वर्ड्स वड्स एंड
इज टर्मिनेटेड
टर्मिनेटेड
इज
बाय कोरे
स्पंग बाय को स्पंग रिजर्व
वर्ड रिजर्व वर्ड ओके रिजर्व
वर्ड्स अब यह रिजर्व वर्ड्स कौन से होते
हैं आपको समझाता ओके मैं आपको बता व कौन
से होते
हैं
तो जो भी कमांड रिज से स्टार्ट होती है और
रिजर्व वर्ड से ही टर्मिनेट होती है वह
कौन सी कमांड कहलाती है कंपाउंड कमांड
होती है अब रिजर्व कौन से होते
हैं
रिजर्व वर्ड्स
मींस
दोज
वर्ड ए वर्ड
ए वर्ड ट
हैज ट हैज
ए
स्पेशल
मीनिंग टू बेस बेस में जिसका कोई स्पेशल
मीनिंग है उनको हम क्या कहते रिजर्व
वर्ड्स कहलाते हैं अब एग्जांपल शो करता
हूं आपको बेसिकली एग्जांपल में शो करता
हूं य एग्जांपल है कि रिजर्व वर्ड भी आ
जाएगा उसके अंदर और ये कंपाउंड कमांड का
एग्जांपल है और
एग्जांपल फॉर
एग्जांपल फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे कि ये
रहा
इफ इफ कमांड है उसके बाद मैंने किया डॉट
इसका समझ में नहीं आ रहा था इस चीज को अभी
इतनी जरूरत नहीं है नेक्स्ट क्लास में
आपको पता चल जाएगी ये क्या चीज है ू हान
जीटी ग्रेटर देन उसके बाद वन
उसके बाद ये क्या कंडीशन है इसके अंदर
सेमीकलन देन उसके बाद क्या है
एंटर
एकको उसके
बाद हेलो
वर्ल्ड देन उसके बाद मैंने एंटर किया उसके
बाद एफ आई एफ आई अब देखो आपको देखने को
मिल रहा स्क्रीन के ऊपर इसको अगर मैं
हाईलाइट करता अलग कलर में हाईलाइट करता
इसको पहली बात तो यह रहा इस कलर में लाइट
करता हूं बोल्ड कर देता हूं
थ बता हूं ये रहा जो इफ है ना इफ एक
रिजर्व वर्ड होता है आपकी बैस में इफ
कंडीशंस होती है वाइल लूप्स होते हैं फोर
लूप्स होते हैं उसी तरीके से ये भी इफ
कंडीशन है यहां पर इफ और बेस में क्या
होता है कि जो इफ है वो इफ से स्टार्ट
होता है देन यहां पर क्या है कंडीशन मेंशन
करते हैं यहां पर ये आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है यहां पर कंडीशन मेंशन करते हैं
उसके बाद देन लिखते हैं यहां पर हम
कमांड्स लिखते हैं उसके बाद इसको क्लोज
करने के लिए भी पी करते हैं एफ आई वही चीज
है कि कंपाउंड कमांड कौन सी होती है जो एक
रिजर्व वर्ड से स्टार्ट हो रही है और
टर्मिनेट भी रिज वर्ड से ही हो रही है वह
कंपाउंड कमांड्स बेसिकली क्या होता है
कंपाउंड कमांड्स का मतलब क्या है कि वो
बेस की प्रोग्रामिंग है बेस में
प्रोग्रामिंग ही कंपाउंड कमांड्स कहलाती
है और कंपाउंड कमांड्स का अगर आप पर्पस
देखोगे तो उसका बेसिकली पर्पस ये हो सकता
है कि आप जब भी कोई प्रोग्राम लिखते हैं
वो ऐसे नॉर्मली चार पांच कमांड या नॉर्मल
बेसिक सिंपल कमांड खने के लिए तो यूज करते
ही नहीं तो वहां पर क्या या तो आप लॉजिक
लगा रहे होते हो किसी लॉजिक को परफॉर्म
करने के लिए के लिए अदर वाइज दूसरा क्या
है कि आप कोई कंडीशन परफॉर्म करने के लिए
के लिए ही उन कमांड्स का यूज करते हैं उस
उस स्क्रिप्ट को बनाते हैं तो उन्हीं
चीजों के परफॉर्म करने के लिए हम कंपाउंड
कमांड का यूज करते हैं और कंपाउंड कमांड्स
तभी कंसीडर की जाती है जब वो किसी एक
रिजर्व वर्ड से स्टार्ट होती है एक रिजर्व
वर्ड्स पे ही फिनिश होती है और कंपाउंड
कमांड्स के अंदर हम मल्टीपल सिंपल कमांड्स
का यूज करते हैं एक हेलो वर्ल्ड एक क्या
है सिंपल कमांड्स है तो बेसिकली क्या होता
है जो कंपाउंड कमांड्स है इट इज द
कॉमिनेशन ऑफ कंपाउंड कमांड एंड सिंपल
कंपाउंड्स क्योंकि कंपाउंड कमांड्स के अंद
सिंपल कंपाउंड का यूज करते हैं थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्शन के बारे में पता ही नहीं बैस
के अंदर या जो स्टार्टिंग में डायरेक्टली
विदाउट लिनक्स सीखे ही सीधा ही परफॉर्म
करे किसी प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज की कोई
नॉलेज नहीं है उनके लिए थोड़ा क्या है
प्रॉब्लेम हो सकता है अदर वाइज जिसकी
फर्स्ट ही क्लास डायरेक्ट अटेंड करने आ गए
जो कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन तो उसके लिए भी
क्या है प्रोब्लेमे िक है ये क्यों उसको
समझ में नहीं आ रहा चल के आ रहा है तो आई
होप कि समझ में आया कि कंपाउंड कमांड कौन
सी होती है बस इतनी ही होती है अभी क्या
कि जब एक बार सारे स्टेप परफॉर्म हो
जाएंगे ना हमारे सारे के सारे जितने भी
स्टेप परफॉर्म हो जाएंगे उसके बाद मैं एक
बार एग्जांपल के साथ पूरे पूरी कमांड
एगजाम उसको सारे पांचों के पांचों स्टेप
उस पर समझाऊ तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि
ये सारी चीजें होती क्या है कंपाउंड कमांड
क्या होता है और सिंपल कमांड उसम कैसे हुई
टोकन कैसे हुआ तो यह था आपका कमांड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन का स्टेप्स यह था आपका
कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन अब बात करते हैं मैं
एक नया पेज ओपन ले लेता हूं इसमें यह रहा
य मैं नया फेम ले लेता हूं इसी में ही और
मैं इसको क्या करता जूम कर लेता के
लिए इसको
भैया
ऐसे नहीं जम हो जाओग चलो अब नेक्स्ट स्टेप
जो मेरा कंटिन्यू है नेक्स्ट स्टेप आता है
मेरा एक्सपेंशन आता स्टेप थ जो आज मेरा
आता है स्टेप थ ज्यादा बड़ा नहीं है स्टेप
थ के बस स्टेप
थ
स्टेप ्र जिसको हम बोलते हैं
एक्सपेंशन ई एक्स प ए एन एस आई ओ
हम सेल एक्सपें भी बोल सकते देखो क्या
होता है जब एक बार आपका टोकना स्टेप
कंप्लीट हो जाता है उसके बाद वर्ड और रेटर
डिसाइड हो जाते हैं तो यह क्या होता है
एक्सपेंशन है जो वर्ड के ऊपर अप्लाई होता
है किसके परर अपलाई होता है यह वर्ड के
ऊपर अप्लाई होता है वर्ड के ऊपर अप्लाई
होता
है लिख देता
हं वंस
द
ज सेल हैज कंप्लीटेड टोकेनाइजेशन
टी ओ केई एन आई जड एटी टोकना
इजेशन
देन देन इट
विल परफॉर्म परफॉर्म
सेल
एक्सपेंशन
सेल एक्सपेंशन ऑन द
वर्ड्स वर्ड्स इन द इन द कमांड
लाइन कमांड लाइन ओके इन द कमांड लाइन
कमांड लाइन के अंदर जो वर्ड एक बार डिसाइड
हो जाते उनके ऊपर क्या सेल एक्सपेंशन
परफॉर्म किया जाता है अब इसकी क्या है फोर
स्टेज होती
है देर
आर फोर स्टेजेस
ऑफ सेल
एक्सपेंशन एक्सपेंशन की चार स्टेज होती है
व चर कौन होती है मैं आपको बता हूं सबसे
पहली जो आती है आपकी उसको बोलते हैं ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन उसको हम बोलते हैं ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन जिसको हम बोलते स्टेज न क्या
करको स्टेज न लिख देता हूं ऐसे आपको
क्लियर नहीं
होगा
स्टेज जीरो
व स्टेज न ओके ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन जो आपकी
स्टेज
जीटू स्टेज टू जिसको हम
बोलेंगे स्टेज टू में क्या है अल्फा ब्राव
चार होती है स्टेज में चर होती है एक तो
होती है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन नेक्स्ट होती है
आपकी अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन
यर अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन नेक्स्ट जो होता
आपका वो होता कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन स्पेल मिस्टेक हो गया कमान
सब्सीट्यूशन उसके
बाद नेक्स्ट आता है
आपका व आपका इसमें इसी में
ही टिल डे
एक्सपेंशन एक्स पी ए एन एस स्टेज टू के
अंदर नेक्स्ट जो आपकी स्टेज थ आती है
स्टेज थ आती है जीथ उसके अंदर आपका आता
है वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
वर्ड वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग स्टेज फोर में आता
है
आपका स्टेज फोर में आपका आता
ग्लोबिंग ग्लोबिंग आपका आता है ग्लोबिंग
देखो आप लोगों को समझ में नहीं आ रहा बो
सर ये ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन क्या होता है य कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन क्या होता है डेड एक्सपेंशन
वर्ड स्लिटिंग यह सारी क्या चीज है डोंट
वरी हर एक को समझाऊ एक एक पकड़ के समझाऊ
प्रैक्टिकली समझाऊ ऐसा नहीं है कि इसको
मैं ऊपर ऊपर से सम बिल्कुल प्रैक्टिकली
आपको बताने वाला
हूं अब इसको मैं हाईलाइट कर देता हूं आपके
लिए थोड़ा सा अच्छा देखे आपके
लिए ओके तो ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक ये चार स्टेजेस होती
है सेल एक्सपेंशन की ये समझ में आ गया जब
भी टोकेनाइजेशन हो जाए है उसके बाद एक बार
वर्ड डिसाइड हो जाएंगे तो उस वर्ड्स के
ऊपर ये चार स्टेजेस ऑफ एक्सपेंशन अप्लाई
होती है अब क्या है मैं आपको बस इतना
समझाना चाहता हूं कि ये चीजें होते क्या
है आज एक्सपेंशन के बारे में ये
इंट्रोडक्शन उसके बाद य चार ब एक्सपेंशन
पैरामीटर इनको डिटेल में एक एक करके समझाऊ
नेक्स्ट क्लास में अभी मैं आपको इसके बारे
में थोड़ी सी और इंफॉर्मेशन आपको थोड़ी
प्रोवाइड करना
चाहता
नेक्स्ट देखो इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट है सबसे
पहले क्या है कि आप इसको नोट नोट मान लो
इसको कुछ भी समझो नोट समझो इसको नोट वन
क्या है
कि द फर्स्ट
थिंग यू नीड टू
नो नीड टू नो
दैट प एक्स प ए एन एस आई
एक्सपेंशस इन द इन ई
अर्लिया स्टेजेज एक्सपेंशन द स्टेजेज
आर
परफॉर्म परफॉर्म
फर्स्ट मतलब क्या है कि सबसे पहले स्टेज
वाला एक्सटेंशन सबसे पहले परफॉर्म होगा
किसी भी कमांड्स में किसी वर्ड के ऊपर जोन
सा एक्सटेंशन स्टेज वन आएगा तो सबसे पहले
स्टेज वन परफॉर्म होगा स्टेज टू आएगा
स्टेज टू परफॉर्म होगा स्टेज थ्री आ स्टेज
थ्री परफॉर्म होगा स्टेज फोर आएगा स्टेज
फोर आ लेकिन क्या है कि अगर स्टेज वन आ
गया और उससे पहले अगर आपने स्टेज फोर
परफॉर्म किया हो तो सबसे पहले क्या होगा
स्टेज वन परफॉर्म होगा उसके बाद स्टेज फोर
परफॉर्म होगा ऐसा नहीं है कि कोई भी किसी
वक्त परफॉर्म होगा नहीं इनका ये सीक्वेंस
दिया है ये ऐसे ही परफॉर्म होंगे ऐसा नहीं
है फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने लिया कि पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन क्या है
कि आपको स्टेज स्टेज टू है और उसके बाद
क्या है कि ये आपने डिफाइन किया हुआ है
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन के अंदर फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
कैसे एग्जांपल आपको एक एग्जांपल दिखाता
हूं भी आपको ऐसे समझ में नहीं आ रहा होगा
एक एग्जांपल ये
है एग्जांपल यह है आपने क्या
लिखा समझाऊ मैं आपको x आपने कोई भी लिखा x
इ 10 लिखा x इ 10 ये एक वेरिएबल है उसके
बाद आपने क्या किया नेक्स्ट एकको किया
एकको कर दिया उसके बाद डबल कर ली बसेस ये
क्या है ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन आपका आपने लिखा
वन से लेके आप क्या करना चाहते हो 10 तक
आप बार-बार ट 3 4 5 6 7 8 नहीं लिखना
चाहते आप क्या चाहते हो वन से 10 तक क्या
करना चाहते हो अपना आउटपुट ऑटोमेटिक ली
चाहते हो तो आपने यहां पर क्या किया डॉलर
और एक्स कर दिया डॉलर एक्स का मतलब क्या
है कि ये पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन आ गया
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन आ गया क्योंकि ये एक
वेरिएबल है वेरिएबल की वैल्यू प्रिंट करने
के लिए आप क्या करोगे डॉलर सिंबल का यूज
करते थे एक पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन आ गया इधर
तो अब क्या है कि आपने पहले क्या किया
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन स्टेज वन परफॉर्म कर दिया
उसके अंदर क्या है स्टेचू परफॉर्म कर दिया
तो अब क्या हो गया कि सबसे पहले ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो गया उसके बाद बात
आती है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन की लेकिन जब
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म हो गया तो इसका
जो लॉजिक बनता सब न से 10 प्रिंट करने का
वो तो समझ में नहीं आया क्योंकि
डायरेक्टली पहले पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन तो
परफॉर्म होगा ही नहीं तो य लॉजिक गलत है
तो सबसे पहले आपको क्या है कि यहां पर अगर
10 होता न डॉट डट 10 होता तो एक से 10 तक
परफॉर्म करता लेकिन यह परफॉर्म बाद में
होगा ब एक्सशन पहले परम हो उसके डलर एक्स
उसके बाद न ड तो सिंपली क्या आउटपुट आएगा
न ड ड 10 ये आउटपुट में आ जाए क्योंकि समझ
में नहीं आया कि आप करना क्या चाहते थे य
सिंपली है फर्स्ट थिंग यू नीड टू नो
एक्सपेंशन फस्ट दूसरी चीज क्या है आपको
नोट में रखनी है जो नोट
नोट य है कि द सेकंड
थिंग दो आपके दिमाग में होगा सेकंड थिंग
यू नीड टू नो यू नीड टू नो
इज ट
एक्सपेंशन
एक्सपेंशन ट आर इन द
स्म स्टेजेस इन द स्टेम
स्टेजेस र
आर
गिवन सेम प्रायोरिटी प
आर आई ओ सेम प्रायोरिटी
एंड एंड
आ एस आई एंड
सिंपली
परफॉर्म
परफॉर्म इन द
ऑर्डर इन द
डर
दे
फाउंड ऑन
द कमांड
लाइन वेन
इट
रीड्स न इट रीड
फम
लेफ्ट लेफ्ट टू
राइट एक चीज ध्यान में रखना जब भी कोई भी
कमांड आप क्या करते
हो कोई भी कमांड आप क्या अपने टर्मिनल
टाइप करते हो फायर करते हो तो उसको जो रीड
किया जाता है उसको लेफ्ट टू राइट रीड किया
जाता है लेफ्ट टू राइट कैसे
इधर ये रहा यहां पर लेफ्ट टू राइट अगर मैं
इसके ऊपर मेंशन करता हूं किसी भी कमांड को
लेफ्ट टू राइट लीड किया जाता
है लेफ्ट
टू एसटी लेफ्ट टू राइट इस किसी भी कमांड
को क्या किया जाता है रीड किया जाता है ये
रहा किसी भी कमांड को रीड किया जाता है तो
अब जब किसी भी कमांड को लेफ्ट टू राइट रीड
किया जाएगा लेकिन कुछ बार कई टाइम कई बार
आपके सामने ऐसी सिचुएशन आएगी कि स्टेज टू
के जो पैरामीटर्स है वो एक साथ यूज हो रहे
होंगे दो या तीन तो क्योंकि देखो सबकी
प्रायोरिटी सेम है स्टेज टू में सबकी सेम
स्टेज पर है तो सेम प्रायोरिटी है तो इस
कंडीशन में क्या बोलता है कि जब आपकी
कमांड लेफ्ट टू राइट लीड की रीड की जाएगी
उस टाइम पर इनमें से जो पहले आएगा
पैरामीटर अर्थमेटिक कमांड और टिल डेट इनम
से जो पहले आएगा उसको परफॉर्म किया इनम से
जो पहले आएगा क्योंकि सेम प्रायोरिटी है
लेकिन अब कंडीशन क्या है लेफ्ट टू राइट
लेफ्ट टू राइट में जो पहले आ गया उसको
परफॉर्म किया जाएगा एक एग्जांपल अगर मैं
आपको देक दिखाऊ तो एग्जांपल यह है कि चलो
एक एग्जांपल है
मेरा बस अभी एंड करने वाला डोंट वरी
य को मैंने एग्जांपल लिया
कोको डॉलर नेम उसके बाद यह जो मैं लिख रहा
हूं यह आप क्या करते हो अपने टर्मिनल में
टाइप करते हो या कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट लिखोगे
तब यूज करते हो मैं कुछ भी नहीं ऐसा अपने
पास से लिख रहा हो जितने भी एक को साथ
लिखा कि आपने टर्मिनल टाइप कर सकता
टर्मिनल इसलिए यूज नहीं कर रहा क्योंकि
टर्मिनल प भी शो कर दूं तो कोई इशू नहीं
होगा आपके लिए बट देखो ये सारी चीजें अभी
तक जो अभी तक सी स टर्मिनल पे ही कर रहा
हूं आगे सामने टर्मिनल होता उस फायर करते
हो आप ये कर सकते हो ऐसे एकको अब मैंने
क्या एकको डॉलर नेम लिखा हैज जज उसके बाद
मैंने क्या लिया
डॉलर फिर उसके बाद मैंने
ये ये उसके बाद वनके बाद प्लस उसके बाद टू
ये एक अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन है यह रहा यह
एक अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन है
एल्स अब देखो इसमें क्या हो रहा है सबसे
पहले आया आपका पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन यह कौन
सा आपका सबसे पहले है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन य रहा आपका य आपका पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन है उसके बाद क्या
है
यह रहा यह आपका है अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
कौन सा है अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन बात करता इसकी य कल
सी य पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन
पैरामीटर पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है थो छोटा
कर देता आपको समझ में आ जाएगा इधर रता
इसको कर देता य पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन डॉलर
नेम उसके बाद ये क्या
है यह अर्थमेटिक
है
एमटी आई अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन य आपका है
अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक क्या होता ज प्लस ड
एडिशन सक्शन हो रहा होता है ओके य आपका
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन तो अब ये क्या बोला
था दोनों पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन और अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन क्या है सेम स्टेज पर है ये रहा
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक तो लेफ्ट टू
राइट कमांड पड़ी जाएगी ये रहा ये अगर मैं
इसको उठा के इधर लेके आता हूं ये रहा
कमांड को ऐसे ही रीड किया जाएगा लेफ्ट टू
राइट लेफ्ट टू राइट कमांड को रीड किया
जाएगा तो अब सबसे पहले पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
है तो इसको एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा उसके
बाद अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन को एग्जीक्यूट
किया जाएगा अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन को
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा फॉर एग्जांपल एक और
एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं आपको कंट्रोल सी करता
हूं इधर
एपल करता
ह ये एक एग्जांपल याया मैंने डलर नेम उसके
बाद मैंने यहां पर क्या कर डलर नेम हैज उ
कली ब्रेस दो उसके बाद मैंने किया न ड ड
10 देन उसके बाद मैंने क्या लिखा
एल्स एंड उसके बाद मैंने डॉलर फिर से यूज
किया यह यूज किया देन वन उसके बाद प्लस
में टू उसके बाद फिर से मैंने य यूज किया
देन ऑरेंज ओ आर ए एन जी ई एस ऑरेंज ओके
उसको फुल स्टॉप कर दिया अब आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं ये सबसे पहले पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन है आपको अगर मैं कंट्रोल से
करता हूं यहां पर लगा देता हूं कंट्रोल ब
ये रहा अरे
यार एक्स
ठीक ये रहा ये आपका है पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन ये समझ में आई आपका पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन और उसके बाद मैं ये दिखाऊं आपको
जो ये
है ये आपका
है ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन ये आपका है ब्रेस
एक्सपेंशन ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन ओके और जो ये
लास्ट में बच गया ये आपका
है ये
रहा अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन कंट्रोल सी ये
आपका है अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन अभी आप बताइए खुद से
ही कि जब यह कमांड एग्जीक्यूट होगी तो
इसमें वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर डिवाइड हो जाएंगे
तो जब वर्ड जो डिवाइड होंगे वर्ड्स के
ऊपर जो सीक्वेंस है पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन और अर्थमेटिक एक्स सबसे
पहले कौन सा इसमें एी क्यूट होगा सबसे
पहले कौन सा एक्यूट देख ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन
स्टेज वन है तो सबसे पहले जो एग्जीक्यूट
होगा इसमें जिसका सबसे पहले जो ये होगा
ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन ओके देन उसके बाद जो आपका
आ गया स्टेज टू में पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
क्योंकि लेफ्ट टू राइट आपकी कमांड पढ़ी जा
रही है उसके बाद फिर आपका अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन परफॉर्म होगा फर्स्ट ये फर्स्ट
ये सेकंड ये थर्ड होगा लेफ्ट टू राइट में
क्या जो जिनकी प्रायोरिटी सेम है वो लेफ्ट
टू राइट में जो पहले आया उसको परफॉर्म
किया जाएगा लेकिन अगर जिसकी प्रायोरिटी
सबसे हाई स्टेज वन तो वो सबसे पहले
परफॉर्म होगा फ इसमें लेफ्ट टू राइट देखा
नहीं जाता ओके तो ये कांसेप्ट था आज का जो
मुझे बताना था आपको कि स्टेप जो थ्री है
स्टेप थी जो एक्सपेंशन में उसमें क्या है
कि टोकेनाइजेशन के बाद जो वर्ड्स होता है
उसके ऊपर सेल एक्सप्रेशन परफॉर्म किया
जाता है इसके चार स्टेजेस होती है स्टेज
वन टूथ फो टू में क्या चार होते हैं उसकी
कुछ कंडीशंस है और बाकी उससे पहले नोट वन
नोट टू आपको ध्यान से समझ लेना चाहिए अगर
मैं इसको हाईलाइट करूं मैं यह
रहा ब्लैक कर देता हूं ये रहा नट व टू
आपको समझ समझ जाना चाहिए कि यह क्या चीज
है ओके तो उसके बाद जब कल हम करने वाले
हैं नेक्स्ट जो क्लास होगी उसमें हम
पढ़ेंगे कि ब्रेस एक्सपेंशन पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन टिल डेट एक्सपेंशन वर्ड
स्लिटिंग ग्लोबिंग हर एक के बारे में हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं थ्योरी प्लस प्रैक्टिकल बट
मोस्टली ये प्रैक्टिकल है इनमें थ्योरी
नहीं है मोस्टली प्रैक्टिकल है एक दो में
थ्योरी है लेकिन साथ में प्रैक्टिकल है
अभी तो प्रैक्टिकली करने वाले हैं तो आई
होप कि किसी का को कोई डाउट बचा है तो पूछ
सकता है अभी स्टिल भी किसी को डाउट है तो
वैसे चार लोग बचे हैं मुझे लगता नहीं कि
चार कोई आप लोगों में से ही होंगे तो किसी
को कोई समझ में नहीं तो दे टू मिनट्स फॉर
डाउट सेशन अदर वाइज फिर हम सेशन को एंड कर
देंगे तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम
मिलेंगे
हां हार्दिक वही समझता हूं मैं कोई मुझे
लगता नहीं कोई आया है लोगों को क्या ना कि
पकी पकाई चीज दे दो तो वह उनको इंटरेस्ट
आता है कि अगर यहीं पर मैं क्या है कोई
टूल बता दूंगा और जिसमें टूल से क्या कुछ
जादू हो जाएगा ना अगर वो चीज बताऊंगा ना
तो जादू वाली चीज के लिए सब आ जाएंगे यहां
पर मिलियन व्यू सब कुछ हो जाएगा बट क्या
है कि अब इसमें जादू हो नहीं क्योंकि
इसमें चीजें सीखनी पड़ेंगी और सीखने के
साथ-साथ फिर क्या करना पड़ेगा उनको
एग्जीक्यूट करना होगा समझना होगा और जब
जहां पर बात दिमाग चलाने की आ जाती है
जहां पर समझना समझने की बात आ जाती है
वहां पर क्या है कि उन्हें पसंद नहीं है
चीजें लोगों को ये चीज सीखने आएंगे लेकिन
जब इन्हें जरूरत होगी वो सीखने आएंगे मैं
इस बात की गारंटी ले रहा हूं कि आज नहीं
तो कल लोग इसे सीखने के लिए दोबारा इसी
चैनल प और इसी चीज को सीखने आएंगे क्योंकि
यही चीज पेड में कोई सिखाएगा ना तो उसको
बोलेंगे तो डि फोनिक्स चैनल के ऊपर फ्री
में अवेलेबल है मैं पैसे क्यों दूं यार
मैंने मिस कर दिया मैं ये क्यों नहीं सीखा
अभी मेरे एक स्टूडेंट है कि मैं नाम नहीं
लूंगा उसको मैंने बोला लिनक्स सीख लो नक्
सीख लो लिनक्स सीख लो बट क्या कि जब मैंने
उसको टास्क परफॉर्म करवाया जब लाइव लैब्स
करवाई जब ट्राई हैक में की जब उसे तो वहां
पर लिनस की सबसे ज्यादा प्रिविलेज सबसे
ज्यादा जरूरत पड़ी उसे कुछ कमांड सीडी
कमांड या कॉपी कट के अलावा कुछ आता नहीं
था उसके फ्यूज उड़े
फिर से क्या है उसने हमारी डिमक्स चैनल से
15 डेज वाली क्लास को नोट बना के सीखना
शुरू किया थी क्लास को कवर कर चुकी कु
चुका है ओके तो समझिए कि इसकी वैल्यू इ
अभी नहीं बाद में पता चल जाएगा इटस ओके
कोई बात नहीं हम सेशन एंड करते
हैं तो थैंक यू गाइस बाय बाय टेक केयर गुड
डे सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन